Figuring out what makes a terrorist tick is not easy, and law enforcement and counterterrorism officials have been turning more and more to psychologists to try to do just that. In this episode, we talk with a psychologist who has spoken face-to-face with former members of violent extremist organizations in an effort to understand how and why people become involved in terrorism, as well as why some choose to walk away. John Hogan is Professor of Security Studies at the School of Criminology and Justice Studies, at the University of Massachusetts Lowell, where he is also the director of the Center for Terrorism and Security Studies. His research focuses on terrorist behavior. He has more than 70 publications
弄清楚是什么促成了恐怖分子的心理并非易事，执法和反恐官员越来越多地求助于心理学家来做这件事。在本期节目中，我们采访了一位心理学家，他曾与暴力极端主义组织的前成员面对面交谈，试图了解人们如何以及为什么会参与恐怖主义，以及为什么有些人选择退出。约翰·霍根（John Hogan）是马萨诸塞大学洛厄尔分校犯罪学与司法研究学院安全研究教授，他也是恐怖主义与安全研究中心的主任。他的研究重点是恐怖分子的行为。他发表了70多篇关于恐怖主义和政治暴力的出版物。
on terrorism and political violence. He's interviewed hundreds of terrorists around the world. Welcome, Dr. Hogan. Thank you for having me. I guess the most common question is, are there certain characteristics or a profile of the type of person who is most likely to become a terrorist? No is the short answer. It hasn't. stopped us from looking for such a profile, but four decades of psychological research on who becomes a terrorist and why hasn't yet produced any profile. If there is no simple way to profile who might be a terrorist, how do you begin to understand and study terrorist behavior?
关于恐怖主义和政治暴力。他采访了世界各地的数百名恐怖分子。欢迎您，霍根博士。谢谢邀请我。我想最常见的问题是，是否存在某些特征或某种画像，能够描绘出最有可能成为恐怖分子的人群？简短的回答是，没有。但这并没有阻止我们寻找这样的人画像，但四十年关于谁会成为恐怖分子以及原因的心理学研究，尚未产生任何画像。如果说没有简单的方法来为可能成为恐怖分子的人画画像，那么你是如何开始理解和研究恐怖分子行为的呢？
Very slowly and with a great deal of patience. We've discovered in recent years that it is possible for us to reach out to and identify individuals who have disengaged from terrorism. So we can actually ask questions to people who were once involved in high-profile terrorist activity. So we can conduct research. We can conduct research systematically, and we can try to answer questions about who becomes involved in terrorism and why. I think it's fair to say that we are at the very, very early stages in terms of developing a science of terrorist behavior. psychology as a discipline hasn't yet contributed very, very much to the study of terrorism. So we've got a long, long way to go. In the case of the Boston Marathon bombings, was there anything about that
非常缓慢，而且需要极大的耐心。近年来我们发现，我们有可能接触并识别出那些已经脱离恐怖主义的人。所以我们实际上可以向曾经参与备受瞩目的恐怖活动的人提问。因此我们可以进行研究。我们可以系统地进行研究，并试图回答关于谁参与恐怖主义以及为什么参与的问题。我认为公平地说，在发展恐怖分子行为科学方面，我们还处于非常非常早期的阶段。心理学作为一门学科，对恐怖主义研究的贡献还非常非常小。所以我们还有很长的路要走。就波士顿马拉松爆炸案而言，这次袭击在心理影响、应对措施，以及袭击者本身方面，
attack that you thought was unique in terms of the psychological impact or the response and, you know, just about the attackers themselves? I think it's fair to say that there are still quite a number of unanswered questions surrounding the Boston Marathon bombings. Questions around the perpetrators, their likely motivations. I think what struck me as being particularly, concerning in the wake of the Boston Marathon bombings was the fact that our resilience seems to have taken a quite a substantial hit. This idea that, for example, that this kind of threat essentially posed an existential challenge to security and a national security in the United States, I think, really contributed to the idea that this is very, very much something that was overblown, really. So I think there are some pretty serious questions we're going to have to ask about our ability to bounce back from these kinds of attacks. The more we learn about the nature of the attack, the more we learn about the preparations for it,
有什么你认为独特的地方吗？我认为公平地说，围绕波士顿马拉松爆炸案仍然有相当多的未解之谜。关于肇事者及其可能动机的疑问。我认为在波士顿马拉松爆炸案发生后，最让我感到担忧的是，我们的韧性似乎受到了相当沉重的打击。例如，这种观点认为，这种威胁基本上对美国的国家安全构成了生存挑战，我认为这确实促使人们认为这在很大程度上被夸大了。因此，我认为我们需要就我们从这类袭击中恢复过来的能力提出一些非常严肃的问题。我们对袭击性质了解越多，对袭击准备工作的了解越多，
the more we're finding out that this attack, in all likelihood, couldn't possibly have been prevented. And there was very, very little leakage, very little initial signals that could have alerted people to what these individuals were all about. And that is a certain, it indicates, at least to me, a certain level of risk that we're going to have to live with. You've interviewed hundreds of terrorists. How forthcoming do you think they are in these interviews? Surprisingly, they are forthcoming. I've interviewed about 150 terrorists since about 1995, and we know that approaches can be made. They tend to be cooperative.
我们越发发现，这次袭击按常理来说是不可能被阻止的。几乎没有什么泄密迹象，也没有什么最初的信号能够提醒人们这些人的真实意图。这在某种程度上——至少对我和我而言——表明了我们将不得不承受的某种程度的风险。你采访了数百名恐怖分子。你认为他们在这些采访中的坦诚程度如何？出人意料的是，他们很坦诚。大约从1995年起，我已经采访了大约150名恐怖分子，我们知道方法是可以行得通的。他们往往很合作。
They tend to be facilitative. but only insofar as they see us as academics as possibly a tool for propaganda. There's very often an agenda. Sometimes they want to use us to push a message out there. In some cases where we've been very, very fortunate to speak to disengaged terrorists, they are very willing to talk about their experiences because they want to say how they've changed. They want to say that they want to be able to talk to us about why
他们往往很配合，但前提是他们把我们这些学者视为宣传的潜在工具。这里面往往有某种议程。有时他们想利用我们来传播某种信息。在某些情况下，我们非常幸运能够与脱离恐怖组织的恐怖分子交谈，他们非常愿意谈论自己的经历，因为他们想表达自己是如何改变的。他们想告诉我们，他们希望能够与我们讨论为什么
the dangers exist for young people becoming involved in terrorism nowadays. So they want to talk to us. How difficult, and you mentioned this, disengaging, how difficult is it for terrorists to disengage, so to speak? Are there programs? Is there, you know, how do they go about that? Well, when we started this research a number of years ago, we began with the assumption that once a terrorist, always a terrorist, that once you're in, you're in, and there really is no way out, except in the words of one former terrorist feet first. That's now not the case. We know that just as there is a steady stream of people who become involved in terrorism,
现在年轻人卷入恐怖主义的危险依然存在。所以他们想和我们谈谈。多大难度——你提到了这个，脱离组织——恐怖分子脱离组织有多难，可以说？有没有什么项目？是否有，你知道，他们是怎么做到的？好吧，几年前我们开始这项研究时，我们的假设是“一日为恐怖分子，终身为恐怖分子”，一旦你加入就身不由己了，真的没有退路，用一位前恐怖分子的话来说，只能“双脚朝前”地离开。现在情况并非如此。我们知道，就像源源不断有人卷入恐怖主义一样，
there's also a fairly steady and regular stream of people who disengage. It's not as difficult as we would have once imagined for people to actually leave, and people leave for a gamut of reasons. There is a variety of push and pull factors that contribute to that, and this is what our current research is trying to uncover. In particular, we found that disillusionment plays a very, very significant role in individuals' decisions, rather, to want to leave behind terrorism. Are there de-radicalization programs out there?
也有一股相当稳定且规律的人群选择脱离。对于人们真正离开来说，并没有我们以前想象的那么困难，人们离开的原因形形色色。推动和拉动因素有多种，这也是我们目前的研究试图揭示的内容。特别是，我们发现幻灭感在个人决定（或者说想要）抛弃恐怖主义的过程中发挥了非常非常显著的作用。目前是否存在去极端化项目？
There certainly are many de-radicalization programs out there. We've started to see the emergency of these programs around about 2003, 2004, and now, I mean, they've really proliferated. I've spent a lot of time in Pakistan this. year. In fact, I've spent a time looking at many of these de-radicalization programs. Some are more effective than others. Some of the work we're doing in Pakistan right now is about understanding how individuals who have been detained for terrorist offenses can effectively be rehabilitated and reintegrated back into the communities that they once claimed to act on behalf of. Is there a way to identify potential terrorists and to prevent them from
当然有很多去极端化项目。我们开始看到这些项目在2003年、2004年左右涌现，现在，我的意思是，它们真的激增了。今年我在巴基斯坦呆了很长时间。事实上，我花了很多时间研究其中许多去极端化项目。有些比其他的更有效。我们目前在巴基斯坦开展的一些工作，是关于了解如何让因涉恐罪行而被拘留的个人得到有效的改造，并重新融入他们曾经声称代表的社区。有没有办法识别潜在的恐怖分子并阻止他们
engaging in terrorism? I think it's becoming very, very difficult to identify potential terrorists. In recent years, we've had a very emotional and a very, I suppose, engaging conversation about who becomes a terrorist and why. And that discussion has been rooted in this concept of radicalization. And one of the assumptions in that has been that people become radicalized. They get exposed to certain kinds of thoughts, certain kinds of ideas, and that then somehow puts them at greater risk for involvement in terrorism. The more evidence we're finding, particularly from firsthand interviews with former terrorists, is that that logic may not necessarily hold in very, very many cases, as intuitive as it might seem. So we're finding right now that the initial concept of radicalization
参与恐怖主义？我认为识别潜在恐怖分子变得非常非常困难。近年来，我们进行了一场非常情绪化且非常引人入胜的对话，探讨谁会成为恐怖分子以及原因。这场讨论一直扎根于“激进化”这个概念。其中的一个假设是，人们会被激进化。他们接触到某种思想、某种观念，然后不知怎么的，这就让他们参与恐怖主义的风险更大。我们发现越来越多的证据，特别是通过对前恐怖分子的第一手采访，这种逻辑在很多很多情况下可能并不一定成立，尽管它看起来可能很直观。所以我们现在发现，最初的激进化概念
isn't as helpful as we once thought, and certainly we need to go back to basics with respect to much of the research here. And this is where I implore more and more psychologists to step up and engage with the kinds of theories, the kinds of methodological frameworks that we have at our disposal to really cut beyond a lot of the otherwise very woolly thinking in this area. Well, thank you, Dr. Horan. This has been very interesting. Thanks for joining us. It's my pleasure. For more information and links to Dr. Horgan's work with the Center for Terrorism and Security Studies at UMass Lowell, please visit our website.
并不像我们曾经认为的那样有用，当然，在很大程度上，我们需要回归这项研究的基础。正因如此，我恳求越来越多的心理学家挺身而出，运用我们手头掌握的各种理论、各种方法论框架，真正穿透这一领域中那些原本非常模糊的思维。好的，谢谢你，霍根博士。这非常有趣。谢谢你加入我们。不客气。欲了解更多信息以及霍根博士在马萨诸塞大学洛厄尔分校恐怖主义与安全研究中心的工作链接，请访问我们的网站。
at speaking of psychology.org. Thank you for joining us. I'm Andre Hamilton with the American Psychological Association's Speaking of Psychology. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网址为 speaking of psychology.org。感谢您的收听。我是来自美国心理学会《心理学热话》的安德烈·汉密尔顿。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。